eu queria que este e de produtos
imaginar em uma revolução só fecha os
olhos rapidamente e imagine uma
revolução
ok por acaso apareceram imagens comum
essa algum tipo de manifestação nas ruas
de confrontos armados
independente do tipo de imagem que vocês
imaginaram se eu perguntar pra vocês
exatamente onde vocês estavam nessa cena
vocês conseguem responder não
isso era previsível porque as pessoas
não escolhem as revoluções
ao contrário são as revoluções que
escolhem as pessoas e hoje eu vim falar
de uma revolução que é diferente
eu quero tarso que levante a mão agora
quem já fez 60 anos quem já pensou em
fazer ou quem conhece pelo menos uma
pessoa que tem 60 anos ou mais
ok
hoje existem mais pessoas vivas com 60
anos de idade ou mais do que o somatório
de todas as pessoas que alcançaram a
cidade ao longo de toda a história a
cada um segundo duas pessoas celebra os
60 anos de vida
eu vim falar de uma revolução que já é
uma das maiores conquistas da humanidade
uma revolução que não é sobre um grupo
ou outro como vocês acabaram de ver uma
revolução que é sobre todos nós ea
evolução da longevidade e porque eu digo
que ela sobre todos nós porque hoje a
gente sabe que o envelhecimento é um
processo que ocorre durante todo o curso
de vida
ninguém dorme jovem e acorda velho só
porque fez 60 anos nós envelhecemos
desde o dia que nascemos
então desse ponto de vista somos todos
velhos em algum grau
mas essa história vai bem além disso
porque nunca na história da humanidade
um contingente tão grande de pessoas
alcançou níveis tão elevados de
longevidade isso significa que nós não
estamos nós estamos envelhecendo apenas
como indivíduos
nós estamos envelhecendo enquanto
sociedade em 2050 64 países vão ter 30
por cento da sua população com mais de
60 anos de idade
isso não é exclusividade dos países
ricos como a gente
naturalmente poderia pensar muito pelo
contrário nessa lista estão quase todos
os países da américa latina maior parte
da ásia inclusive a china e até mesmo
países como índia indonésia e nigéria já
se encontram no ranking de longevidade
também e pela primeira vez as a
humanidade vai chegar um ponto em que
haverá nem nos crianças do que pessoas
idosas
isso é pra gente pensar falando
especificamente do brasil
nós somos estamos entre os três países
que vão envelhecer mais rapidamente nos
próximos 20 anos de acordo com o ibge é
hoje de cada 100 pessoas 12 são idosas
mas isso vai mudar em 2050
de cada 100 pessoas 30 vôos e idosos
eu gosto muito de olhar para os números
porque isso eles mostram claramente que
o envelhecimento populacional é um game
change que significa isso
o game em geral um fenômeno que muda
todas as regras do jogo em todos os
campos da vida em sociedade das coisas
mais complexas como a economia de um
país as coisas mais simples como uma
brincadeira de criança
vou tratá-lo uma coisa tem nada a ver
com a outra
quando as crianças brincam de casinha de
boneca por exemplo elas estão aprendendo
a cuidar
geralmente da casa e de um filho
imaginar uma criança também
mas a revolução na longevidade vai dar
uma nova função uma nova atribuição a
essa brincadeira tão simples tão
inocente que é aprender a fazer com que
meninas e também menino hoje
aprendam a cultura de cuidado com os
próprios pais
o que esses pais vão viver mais e talvez
até melhor mas eles não vão viver livres
de doenças crônicas como devem ser
câncer
eu passei por isso com o meu pai o ano
acabou de passar com isso por isso a
situação com a mãe dela também
mas se fosse nosso envelhecer é uma
bosta
eu não quero isso né
mas não é bem assim é até porque a única
alternativa que a gente tem por enquanto
apesar de todos os avanços tecnológicos
se você não quer envelhecer a única
alternativa morrer cedo né
mas como vocês já sabem que todos nós
fazemos parte você já tem essa
consciência de que todos nós fazemos
parte dessa revolução eu quero convidar
você levar essa discussão um outro nível
e para isso é preciso começar dizendo
que envelhecer não é o problema
o problema real que a gente enfrenta
hoje é o risco da má gestão do
envelhecimento populacional isso é tão
sério que o fórum econômico mundial em
2013 elegeu o envelhecimento
populacional que vê a má gestão do
envelhecimento populacional como um dos
maiores riscos para a economia global
comparando a escassez de água a falta de
alimentos e as desigualdades sociais
o mais que chama mais atenção é que
apesar de todos esses números todas
essas coisas que eu tomo estanque
rapidamente pra vocês
a gente continua insistindo em lidar com
o fato que é inédito na história da
humanidade que é um desafio do século 21
com uma mentalidade com o padrão de
pensamento do século 19 é é aqui vou dar
um exemplo pra vocês
ah eu participei há um tempo atrás de um
projeto que visava melhorar a qualidade
do transporte público para as pessoas
idosas e uma pesquisadora desse projeto
vai vendo falou contou que sofreu um
acidente de carro muito grave que foi
causado por um condutor idoso e aí ela
tomou fia fortemente trabalhado nesse
projeto para que a qualidade dos
transportes públicos melhorasse a que as
pessoas idosos pudessem parar de
foi a maior vergonha que eu senti na
minha vida só de ouvir o que ela falou
isso porque eu acho que em algum momento
a gente falhou e explicar o que
significa que envelhecer como sociedade
deixa eu explicar porque na minha
opinião nem mesmo no meu pensamento essa
ideia dela estava completamente
equivocada primeiro porque ela se
baseava num conceito de velhice que usa
só a idade cronológica como referência e
hoje a gente sabe que a idade
cronológica não determina a condição
física e psicológica das pessoas
principalmente uma fatia que já é tão
grande da população
em segundo lugar porque é essa teoria de
que os jovens ficarão mais seguros no
trânsito
se as pessoas idosas parassem de dirigir
só estava baseado em preconceito em
coisas do imaginário coletivo porque os
dados do denit mostram que as pessoas
idosas condutores idosos só estão
envolvidos em cinco de 100 acidentes de
trânsito e até mesmo as seguradoras
chegam a cobrar por uma apólice para o
idoso cerca de metade do preço que
cobram um jovem que tem o mesmo carro e
mora no mesmo lugar e em terceiro lugar
a terceira isso terceiro lugar
a cia ainda que a gente tivesse
transporte público adequado para as
pessoas idosas no brasil e quem anda de
ônibus trem e metrô
sabe muito bem que a gente está muito
longe disso
não é o direito da pessoa idosa e
dirigir que tem que ser tirado
somos nós que temos que desenvolver
tecnologias que compensa o déficit
natural da idade acredita que isso já é
possível
white nos estados unidos tem um
laboratório que trabalha exclusivamente
com pesquisa de longevidade e eles já
desenvolveram um carro que sente o que
você sente que aprende o teu estilo de
direção e aí como retorno ele te ajuda a
dirigir é um laboratório que trabalhos
como foi esse carro foi criado um
laboratório que trabalha exclusivamente
para atender à demanda de uma sociedade
que está envelhecendo
você também deve ter vindo por aí
que o próprio google já está testando um
veículo autônomo ou seja que não precisa
de motorista e isso também vai atender
muito bem as demandas das pessoas idosas
então o que eu tô falando aqui é que
enxergar os limites do envelhecimento é
muito diferente de se submeter disse
aceitar esses limites
é o que a gente precisa fazer na verdade
a entender como envelhecimento
populacional está mudando o
funcionamento do mundo ea forma como nós
atuamos nele
foi isso que fizeram também recentemente
empresas como microsoft ibm apple e
google que decidiram recentemente que
além de serem gigantes em tecnologia
elas também não sei gigantes em
longevidade e saúde então já lançaram
diversos produtos relacionados a isso
só para lembrar essas decisões não são
tomadas por empresas são tomadas por
pessoas e é nesse processo que eu
acredito que cada um de nós aqui pode
contribuir
uma pergunta que pode guiar é essa
iniciativa é o que eu posso fazer com as
habilidades que eu tenho hoje pra
contribuir com a evolução da longevidade
de uma forma inovadora com um novo
pensamento eu comecei de forma muito
simples vocês podem pensar em si nos
seus papéis na família na comunidade na
universidade e no trabalho
a minha forma de começar foi com a minha
mãe que está aqui algumas pessoas já
devem ter visto pela circulando por aí
aprontando algumas coisas e saber que
ela não estou vendo daqui e ela tinha
uma profissão ela trabalhava trabalhava
como manicure a vida inteira e mais e
manicure uma profissão é ergonomicamente
muito difícil de manter na velhice
então só que ela não queria parar de
trabalhar porque trabalho e dar a ela a
autonomia não é então ela é o futebol
mandou pensa
alguma alternativa e aí a gente sentou
junto viu quais eram os medos pesaram as
expectativas o que podia o que a gente
podia inventar e aí
hoje ela trabalha como artesã se
reinventou depois dos 60 anos
e aí depois disso comecei a fotografar
outras pessoas idosas que continuavam
trabalhando esses essa por exemplo é uma
vizinha nossa é que o conhece desde a
infância que é é a nova do sul também e
eu fotografei um monte de pessoas foi
uma coisa super divertida e aí depois
disso tudo que eu fui fazer visava
sempre resolver um problema real então
fui fazer mestrado na universidade
federal do rio de janeiro e lá fez uma
pesquisa que procurava entender por que
essas pessoas idosas que já podiam até
aposentados e ter parado de trabalhar
que iriam continuar trabalhando então a
gente concluiu que existiam 8 motivações
principais para elas continuam querendo
continuar trabalhando
daí eu fiz uma triangulação com uma
simulação que uma empresa de fora boston
consulting group fez que mostra que no
ano de 2030 das 15 principais economias
do mundo das 15 maiores não é o brasil
vai ser que vai enfrentar o que vai
enfrentar maior déficit de mão de obra
qualificada
então quando eu olho para o resultado
dessas duas pesquisas já posso pensar em
muita coisa
na primeira delas é que coisas práticas
que eram muito bem sucedidas no passado
hoje são erros estratégicos por exemplo
incentiva a aposentadoria precoce de
trabalhadores que ainda estão com 50
anos de idade
é um erro estratégico e não é só por
causa desse papo da falência de
previdência social
é porque eles querem e podem trabalhar é
porque eles vão ser ao a melhor se a
única senão a melhor alternativa para
lidar com esse déficit de mão de obra
qualificada que nós vamos enfrentar logo
ali
daqui a 15 anos a outra coisa que dá pra
saber que dá pra fazer
começar a quebrar paradigmas então dá
pra criar novas formas de aposentadoria
porque uma pessoa dorme um trabalhador e
acorda aposentada de forma tão abrupta
vão criar uma aposentadoria faseado dá
pra você pensar também em novos regimes
de tráfego que não sejam a clt
então vamos criar regimes professores
que não querem trabalhar 44 horas por
semana mas querem e podem trabalhar
vamos criar como empresas centros de de
convivência onde pessoas como eu e como
a ana que tivemos que cuidar de pais é
com doenças crônicas que demandam
cuidados especiais do longo durante
longo tempo possam deixar os seus pais
com atenção e cuidado enquanto ela de
trabalho ea empresa ganha conhece porque
as pessoas conseguem manter a
produtividade não precisam faltar
elas não vão ser assistidas para isso né
vamos pensar talvez em uma licença
equivalente à maternidade
só que em vez de cuidar de uma criança
que está no extremo da vida eu vou
cuidar do adulto que está no final e dá
pra gente ajudar muito mais gente
com base nessas 62 mil resultados dessas
mesmas pesquisas só que pensam em novas
aplicações
então se eu pegar por exemplo o
trabalhador que o idoso que continuar
trabalhando porque tem necessidade
financeira e por que quer conservar as
relações sociais
eu posso criar um projeto por exemplo
que gere renda extra para a pessoa idosa
que também é ajude a manter manter essa
pessoa idosa nas a melhor inserção
digamos a participação social dessa
pessoa e de quebra e ainda contribui
para mudar a mentalidade dos outros das
pessoas em relação à velhice
então foi isso que a gente fez lá no
laboratório quando a gente criou o
projeto rio vivido há inicialmente ele a
gente a gente pensou que ele seria uma
plataforma de reserva de quartos na casa
das pessoas idosas para turistas
só que no meio do caminho a gente
percebeu que os quatro não tinham
importância porque as histórias que as
pessoas contavam para a gente era tão
legais que a gente fosse vão mudar
o projeto tudo tem uma dúvida tudo
errado
o que a gente fez nós fizemos um
processo de storytelling com eles e aí o
que a gente tem hoje é um site que tem
vários vídeos de dois minutos são vídeos
curtinhos que é estrelado pelos próprios
idosos né
e eles contam e mostram um pouco da
história de vida e da rotina deles então
quando o turista entra no site
ele não vê quarto e viajante ele ver
histórias e aí ele escolhe seus pedais
com aqueles que eles têm mais afinidade
pegar esse aqui é o jorge tac na ponta
né
a edp do dois jovens portugueses de 26
anos de idade
e aí a gente imaginava que quando ele
tivesse uma interação eles iam ensinar
para jorge alguma coisa sobre internet e
tecnologia e como retorno jorge em
ajudar um dique dando dicas sobre o rio
né
só que foi nada disso que aconteceu de
verdade foi que eles saíram no sábado de
manhã os três juntos de casa passaram a
madrugada na rua voltaram cinco horas da
manhã e aí
assim foram os pontos turísticos do rio
que todo mundo vai
mas fizeram coisas que o jorge faz na
rotina dele então é foram na academia da
terceira idade que o espaço aberto na
rua na zona sul foram para a praia andar
de ônibus foram de bar em bar na noite
da lapa que a favor e via e chegada de
cinco horas em casa e uma semana depois
mesmo sem agente do projeto saber eles
repetiram isso e agora combinar que
jorge vai para portugal e aí vai se
hospedar com eles
ah tem muita coisa pra fazer e tem
muitas idéias interessantes também mas a
gente precisa de gente de pessoas para
trabalhar nisso então parte do nosso
trabalho lá no laboratório é formar
pessoas a gente desafia esses meninos
que são alunos da graduação de
engenharia da engenharia de produção da
universidade federal a criar soluções
pra atender demandas cotidianas das
pessoas idosas e o que tem a nossa
estratégia é utilizar técnicas
ferramentas e assunto que a gente sabe
que estão no foco de atenção de
interesse deles como design fink
empreendedorismo inovação social
inovação tecnológica
a gente coloca eles em campo em contato
direto com as pessoas idosas e eles
respondem com um produto ti e serviços
projetados para atender as demandas que
eles se identificaram com as próprias
pessoas
a gente já conseguiu fazer é aplicar
essa esse curso a 140 alunos e teve como
resultado 27 projetos que eles se
dividem em grupos para trabalhar e mais
mais interessante é que além dos
projetos
eles têm esse trabalho tem efeitos
colaterais na empatia na colaboração e
no engajamento então quando eles começam
curso e não sabem ainda o que vão
estudar 23% deles diz que já pensou na
hipótese de projetar para pessoas idosas
qualquer tipo de solução
e aí três meses depois quando o curso
termina a gente repete a mesma pergunta
e esse número sobe de 23 por cento para
77 por cento então 77% dos futuros
engenheiros que estavam pensando apenas
no mercado financeiro nas plataformas de
petróleo e gás do rio ou coisas desse
tipo as empresas mega ano né começam a
pensar em trabalhar mesmo atua
profissionalmente com foco nas pessoas
idosas
então não precisa ser um especialista a
antes disso uma coisa muito importante
que a gente percebe que quando eles
entendem que o envelhecimento é um
processo pelo qual eles estão bem estão
passando e quando eles entendem que
mesmo antes de se formar para o mercado
eles podem gerar impacto positivo na
vida dessas pessoas
eles mudam completamente a mentalidade
em relação a um pessoa idosa e
envelhecimento né
então o que eu ia dizer é que não
precisa ser nenhum especialista em
longevidade envelhecimento populacional
para perceber que o futuro não é mais
como era antigamente eo presente também
não envelhecer não é só
mas sobre os nossos pais envelhecer é o
destino da nossa espécie
hoje então o que eu tenho visto com
todas essas experiências e alguns outros
projetos que eu participo é que todos os
dias a gente tem pela uma oportunidade
mas normalmente a gente tem muitas
oportunidades de participar com as
nossas habilidades com o conhecimento
que a gente já tem dessa revolução e as
habilidades que cada um de vocês tem
então que daí você pode pensar que o
processo você pode mudar o conceito você
pode ensinar o que produto ou serviço
você pode criar
não tô aqui dizendo que isso é fácil a
gente corre riscos lá mas como disse o
recuo revolucionário chamado trotsky
aquele que se ajoelha diante do fato
consumado não é capaz de enfrentar o
futuro então você vai ficar aí a
conformado com a idéia de velhice do
século retrasado ou vai ter coragem de
agarrar a revolução que tite escolheu